So wait, let me ask a potentially a question that will show my ignorance about how GPUs work. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 80 recorded on May 26, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about C++ multidimensional iterators, MD-SPAN, MD-ARRAY, GPUs, and more. Then, sir, we shall continue. All right, what are we talking about? You're keynoting at array. Breaking news. As of when?
So wait, let me ask a potentially a question that will show my ignorance about how GPUs work. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 80 recorded on May 26, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about C++ multidimensional iterators, MD-SPAN, MD-ARRAY, GPUs, and more. Then, sir, we shall continue. All right, what are we talking about? You're keynoting at array. Breaking news. As of when?|||等一下，让我问一个可能会暴露我对GPU工作原理无知的潜在问题。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 80 期，录制于 2022 年 5 月 26 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起讨论 C++ 多维迭代器、MD-SPAN、MD-ARRAY、GPU 等等。那么，先生，我们继续吧。好的，我们在聊什么？你要在 Array 会议上做主旨演讲。突发新闻。从什么时候开始？
24 hours ago? 36 hours ago? Yeah. Bryce will be keynoting at the Array 2022 conference taking place in San Diego on June 13th, 2022. Why do I know the exact dates of this conference of which Bryce is keynoting at? Because I will also be presenting. Not keynoting though. Because I actually did the heavy lifting of writing a paper, getting it accepted, and therefore now I get to present. I just got an email from people and I was like, sure.
24 hours ago? 36 hours ago? Yeah. Bryce will be keynoting at the Array 2022 conference taking place in San Diego on June 13th, 2022. Why do I know the exact dates of this conference of which Bryce is keynoting at? Because I will also be presenting. Not keynoting though. Because I actually did the heavy lifting of writing a paper, getting it accepted, and therefore now I get to present. I just got an email from people and I was like, sure.|||24小时前？36小时前？是的。Bryce 将在 2022 年 6 月 13 日于圣地亚哥举行的 Array 2022 会议上做主旨演讲。为什么我知道 Bryce 做主旨演讲的这个会议的确切日期？因为我也会做报告。不过不是主旨演讲。因为我 realmente 干了重活——写了一篇论文，被录用了，所以现在我得以做报告。我刚收到人们的邮件，然后我就想，行吧。
And then I booked some flights. This is the difference. Remember that one time when I was like, you know, you'll go on to be CEO of some company one day and I'll do things. This is the difference between you and me bryce you get invited to do i'll be i'll be keeping on that i'm going to be keynoting at a workshop at europar in august europar yeah it's a hbc conference nice nice where's that taking place in scotland glasgow? Well, I was about to do a Scottish accent, but I decided not to. That's probably.
And then I booked some flights. This is the difference. Remember that one time when I was like, you know, you'll go on to be CEO of some company one day and I'll do things. This is the difference between you and me bryce you get invited to do i'll be i'll be keeping on that i'm going to be keynoting at a workshop at europar in august europar yeah it's a hbc conference nice nice where's that taking place in scotland glasglasgow? Well, I was about to do a Scottish accent, but I decided not to. That's probably.|||然后我订了一些机票。这就是区别。还记得有一次我说，你知道的，你以后会成为某家公司的CEO，而我会做一些事情。这就是你和我的区别，Bryce，你受到邀请去……我会继续关注，我将在 8 月份在 EuroPar 的一个研讨会上做主旨演讲。EuroPar，是的，这是一个 HPC 会议。不错，不错。那在哪里举行？苏格兰，格拉斯哥？嗯，我本想模仿苏格兰口音，但还是决定算了。那样可能会……
When we, the last time that Connor and I were in Ireland, in Northern Ireland. Visiting my sister, who is now recently married. Congratulations, Kieran. But your sister is not in Northern Ireland. But yes, congratulations. Right. Not Northern Ireland. But I mean, we did go down to Dublin.
When we, the last time that Connor and I were in Ireland, in Northern Ireland. Visiting my sister, who is now recently married. Congratulations, Kieran. But your sister is not in Northern Ireland. But yes, congratulations. Right. Not Northern Ireland. But I mean, we did go down to Dublin.|||当时我们……我和 Connor 上一次去爱尔兰、去北爱尔兰的时候。去拜访了我刚结婚不久的妹妹。恭喜你，Kieran。但你妹妹不在北爱尔兰。不过是的，恭喜。对。不是北爱尔兰。但我的意思是，我们确实去了都柏林。
We took a bus down to Dublin. And Connor, who is what percentage Irish are you? We'll round up and say 50%. 50% Irish. Connor, who is some percentage Irish. If you go by the number of names in my name, Connor with one N, Patrick, those are like two of the most Irish names,
We took a bus down to Dublin. And Connor, who is what percentage Irish are you? We'll round up and say 50%. 50% Irish. Connor, who is some percentage Irish. If you go by the number of names in my name, Connor with one N, Patrick, those are like two of the most Irish names,|||我们坐大巴去了都柏林。Connor，你身上有多少比例的爱尔兰血统？我们四舍五入说 50% 吧。50% 的爱尔兰血统。Connor，一个有着某种比例爱尔兰血统的人。如果你看我名字里的名字数量，单写一个 N 的 Connor，Patrick，那简直是两个最具爱尔兰特色的名字，
and then my last name is dutch hookstra so i'm 67 on irish by name by name dear listener you may be beginning to see the problem here i also love mashed potatoes my favorite food in the world potatoes are the best connor what seemed to be under the impression that he was a lot more irish than he actually was and so we got to dublin and connor connor during most of this trip had been rolling out his irish accent in northern ireland um and uh and i kept telling him dude you're gonna're going to get us killed. You are going to get us killed. And then we meet up with Connor's sister, Kieran, and it's Jack. Yeah, Jack. Good memory. And her boyfriend, now husband, Jack.
and then my last name is dutch hookstra so i'm 67 on irish by name by name dear listener you may be beginning to see the problem here i also love mashed potatoes my favorite food in the world potatoes are the best connor what seemed to be under the impression that he was a lot more irish than he actually was and so we got to dublin and connor connor during most of this trip had been rolling out his irish accent in northern ireland um and uh and i kept telling him dude you're gonna're going to get us killed. You are going to get us killed. And then we meet up with Connor's sister, Kieran, and it's Jack. Yeah, Jack. Good memory. And her boyfriend, now husband, Jack.|||然后我的姓是荷兰语的 Hoekstra，所以按名字算我有 67% 的爱尔兰血统。按名字算！亲爱的听众，你可能开始看出问题所在了。我也很喜欢土豆泥，我世界上最喜欢的食物，土豆是最好的。Connor 似乎给人一种印象，觉得自己比实际上的爱尔兰血统要多得多，所以我们到了都柏林，Connor 在这次旅行的大部分时间里一直在北爱尔兰展示他的爱尔兰口音，嗯，呃，我一直在告诉他，老兄，你会害死我们的。你会害死我们的。然后我们遇到了 Connor 的妹妹 Kieran，还有 Jack。对，Jack。好记性。还有她的男朋友、现在的丈夫 Jack。
And Connor, like, does the accent one more time. And I ask Jack, Jack, is it a good idea for him? Isn't it a bad idea for him to be doing that? Jack is like, yeah. And Connor retired the accent for the rest of the trip. Actually, the picture of us that at least used to be on the ADSP landing page. It's still there. It's still there. 50% is still there.
And Connor, like, does the accent one more time. And I ask Jack, Jack, is it a good idea for him? Isn't it a bad idea for him to be doing that? Jack is like, yeah. And Connor retired the accent for the rest of the trip. Actually, the picture of us that at least used to be on the ADSP landing page. It's still there. It's still there. 50% is still there.|||然后 Connor 就像那样，又用那种口音说了一遍。我问 Jack，Jack，他这么做好吗？他这么做是不是个坏主意？Jack 说，是的。然后 Connor 在接下来的旅程中就不用这种口音了。实际上，我们俩的照片，至少以前在 ADSP 官网上出现过的那张。还在那。还在那。50% 依然在那。
It is from that Ireland trip. Yeah. We were in Phoenix Park with the deer. Yes. Yeah. We were very excited about the deer. And I seem to recall both of us, our shoes got quite soaking wet, but I wisely had brought a spare pair of socks because I knew that my shoes were susceptible to becoming wet.
It is from that Ireland trip. Yeah. We were in Phoenix Park with the deer. Yes. Yeah. We were very excited about the deer. And I seem to recall both of us, our shoes got quite soaking wet, but I wisely had brought a spare pair of socks because I knew that my shoes were susceptible to becoming wet.|||那是那次爱尔兰之旅拍的。是的。我们在菲尼克斯公园和鹿在一起。对。是的。我们对鹿感到非常兴奋。我记得我们俩的鞋都湿透了，但我明智地带了一双备用袜子，因为我知道我的鞋很容易湿。
We went on a day trip that's like a single day trip to dublin and bryce bought brought not bought brought with him an extra pair of socks this is this is the guy that's what this is who we're dealing i knew it was going to be rainy and i knew that my shoes had like if there was any amount of water, my shoes were going to get inundated. And Connor did not. And Connor had a less than pleasant bus ride back to Northern Ireland. It's true. It's true.
We went on a day trip that's like a single day trip to dublin and bryce bought brought not bought brought with him an extra pair of socks this is this is the guy that's what this is who we're dealing i knew it was going to be rainy and i knew that my shoes had like if there was any amount of water, my shoes were going to get inundated. And Connor did not. And Connor had a less than pleasant bus ride back to Northern Ireland. It's true. It's true.|||我们去都柏林进行了一日游，Bryce 买（不，不是买，是带）了一双备用袜子。这就是这个人，这就是我们面对的人。我知道会下雨，我也知道我的鞋子——只要有一点水，我的鞋子就会进水。而 Connor 没有。Connor 坐大巴回北爱尔兰的旅程可不太愉快。是真的。是真的。
My feet were pretty cold the rest of the day. When was that? This was November of 2019, about a few months just before the pandemic. The last time that we had crazy travel plans. See, I didn't think that it was ever going to go back to, you know, going abroad for three or four weeks at a time and doing multiple trips back to back. But I just booked a, I just finished making my London, Tokyo, Toronto travel arrangements. Oh, yeah. in tokyo toronto travel arrangements oh yeah i'm not actually flying directly to toronto because i'm sure toronto is a lovely and big city but there's just not a lot of flights between tokyo and toronto i mean it is it is halfway across the world so instead i'm flying to a real city new york and then then I'm flying to Toronto from New York.
My feet were pretty cold the rest of the day. When was that? This was November of 2019, about a few months just before the pandemic. The last time that we had crazy travel plans. See, I didn't think that it was ever going to go back to, you know, going abroad for three or four weeks at a time and doing multiple trips back to back. But I just booked a, I just finished making my London, Tokyo, Toronto travel arrangements. Oh, yeah. in tokyo toronto travel arrangements oh yeah i'm not actually flying directly to toronto because i'm sure toronto is a lovely and big city but there's just not a lot of flights between tokyo and toronto i mean it is it is halfway across the world so instead i'm flying to a real city new york and then then I'm flying to Toronto from New York.|||那天剩下的时间里我的脚挺冷的。那是什么时候？那是 2019 年 11 月，大流行爆发前几个月。那是我们最后一次有疯狂的旅行计划。你看，我以前以为生活再也不会恢复到那种一次出国三四周、连续进行多次旅行的状态了。但我刚刚预订了……我刚刚做好了伦敦、东京、多伦多的旅行安排。哦，对了。在东京、多伦多的旅行安排……哦，是的，我其实并不是直接飞往多伦多，因为我确信多伦多是一个可爱的大城市，但东京和多伦多之间的航班确实不多。我的意思是，毕竟远在地球的另一端，所以我打算先飞到一个真正的城市——纽约，然后我再从纽约飞往多伦多。
I mean, many people say that Toronto is the New York of Canada. So I, you know. Right. But that's exactly my point, Connor. New York doesn't have to be the New York of anywhere because it's just New York. If your city has to be the X of something else, then just saying in the pyramid of cities, you're not at the very top that's true i mean new york's got to be you know of the iconic cities of the world it's either number one or top three no doubt um yeah yeah and i see that i say that even acknowledging that i'm a Westerner that lives in, like even taking into account, you know, Beijing and other cities. New York's up there.
I mean, many people say that Toronto is the New York of Canada. So I, you know. Right. But that's exactly my point, Connor. New York doesn't have to be the New York of anywhere because it's just New York. If your city has to be the X of something else, then just saying in the pyramid of cities, you're not at the very top that's true i mean new york's got to be you know of the iconic cities of the world it's either number one or top three no doubt um yeah yeah and i see that i say that even acknowledging that i'm a Westerner that lives in, like even taking into account, you know, Beijing and other cities. New York's up there.|||我的意思是，许多人说多伦多是加拿大的纽约。所以我，你知道的。对。但这就是我的重点，Connor。纽约不需要成为任何地方的纽约，因为它就是纽约。如果你的城市必须成为其他某某地方的“X”，那就说明在城市的金字塔中，你们并没有处于最顶端。这倒也是，我的意思是，纽约可以说是世界上最具标志性的城市之一，毫无疑问它不是第一就是前三。嗯，是的，是的，我说这话时甚至承认自己是个西方人，就住在……甚至考虑到北京和其他城市，纽约也是名列前茅的。
So what are you gonna be talking about at this keynote? I will be talking about C++ standard parallelism. I think I will, given the conference is called Array, I'll probably be talking a good bit about things like MD- span um yeah and um and well if i had time i would talk more about the problem multi-dimensional iterators in uh in c plus plus um how long how long is your keynote is it uh it's an hour damn look at that i haven't you get three times as much talking time as me you got 20 minutes oh because i think i'm actually not
So what are you gonna be talking about at this keynote? I will be talking about C++ standard parallelism. I think I will, given the conference is called Array, I'll probably be talking a good bit about things like MD- span um yeah and um and well if i had time i would talk more about the problem multi-dimensional iterators in uh in c plus plus um how long how long is your keynote is it uh it's an hour damn look at that i haven't you get three times as much talking time as me you got 20 minutes oh because i think i'm actually not|||那你这次主旨演讲要讲什么？我将讨论 C++ 标准并行性。我想，既然这个会议叫 Array，我可能会花不少时间讲类似 MD-span 的东西，嗯，还有，嗯，如果我有时间的话，我会多谈谈 C++ 中多维迭代器的问题。嗯，你的主旨演讲有多长时间？是一个小时吗？靠，你看，我还没……你的发言时间是我的三倍。你只有 20 分钟。哦，因为我觉得我其实并不是……
entirely sure because i haven't registered for the conference yet and it's a couple weeks away so i should do that but uh i'm pretty sure academic papers at least in years past they only get 20 minute presentation slots oh yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't be surprised so yeah i mean it is more of an academic conference yeah for those that you don't know array is a conference that focuses on array languages and multi-dimensional libraries and the such so and it's co-located with pldi which is a programming language design and implementation conference that happens every year so multi-dimensional iterators. People who take a look at MD-SPAN that's going to C++23, God willing, might notice that it doesn't have any iterators, which is a bit unfortunate because, you know, we're C++
entirely sure because i haven't registered for the conference yet and it's a couple weeks away so i should do that but uh i'm pretty sure academic papers at least in years past they only get 20 minute presentation slots oh yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't be surprised so yeah i mean it is more of an academic conference yeah for those that you don't know array is a conference that focuses on array languages and multi-dimensional libraries and the such so and it's co-located with pldi which is a programming language design and implementation conference that happens every year so multi-dimensional iterators. People who take a look at MD-SPAN that's going to C++23, God willing, might notice that it doesn't have any iterators, which is a bit unfortunate because, you know, we're C++|||完全确定，因为我还没注册会议，离会议还有几周，所以我应该去注册。但是，我很确定学术论文——至少在过去几年里——只有 20 分钟的演讲时间。哦，对，对，对，我一点也不觉得意外。所以，是的，我的意思是它更像是一个学术会议。对于那些不太了解的人来说，Array 是一个专注于数组语言、多维库等主题的会议。它与 PLDI（每年举行一次的编程语言设计与实现会议）同期同地举行。那么，多维迭代器。那些了解将进入 C++23（如果上帝保佑的话）的 MD-SPAN 的人可能会注意到它没有任何迭代器，这有点遗憾，因为，你知道的，我们是 C++
programmers. We like to be able to take our data structures and data structure-like things and be able to sort them in, well, maybe sort and makes less sense in this context, but do things like count them or do reductions over them or find things in them. And for that, we would get iterators or ranges to those things, and then plug those iterators ranges into the C++ standard algorithms. But you can't do that with MD-SPAN because it doesn't give you iterators.
programmers. We like to be able to take our data structures and data structure-like things and be able to sort them in, well, maybe sort and makes less sense in this context, but do things like count them or do reductions over them or find things in them. And for that, we would get iterators or ranges to those things, and then plug those iterators ranges into the C++ standard algorithms. But you can not do that with MD-SPAN because it doesn't give you iterators.|||程序员。我们喜欢对数据结构以及类似数据结构的东西进行排序——嗯，也许排序在这个语境下意义不大，但我们可以做诸如计数、归约（reduction）或者在其中查找元素之类的事情。为此，我们会获得指向这些东西的迭代器或范围，然后将这些迭代器或范围传入 C++ 标准算法中。但你不能对 MD-SPAN 这样做，因为它不提供迭代器。
And the question that's probably in your mind is why not? Well, it comes down to optimization. We can write multidimensional iterators. And there's sort of two approaches to how you can do it. And neither of them is particularly palatable. And both have performance problems. So the first way to write multidimensional iterator, and we're going to use the 2D case, the 2D matrix case as an example.
And the question that's probably in your mind is why not? Well, it comes down to optimization. We can write multidimensional iterators. And there's sort of two approaches to how you can do it. And neither of them is particularly palatable. And both have performance problems. So the first way to write multidimensional iterator, and we're going to use the 2D case, the 2D matrix case as an example.|||你脑海中可能会浮现出的问题是：为什么不呢？嗯，归根结底是为了优化。我们可以编写多维迭代器。实现它大致有两种方法。但这两种方法都不算特别讨喜，而且都有性能问题。编写多维迭代器的第一种方法——我们以二维情况、二维矩阵情况为例。
So the first way to write a multidimensional iterator is to collapse the indexing. So you sort of end up losing information here. You don't keep track of both i and j. You just keep like one, like where am I in the sequence number? And if you ever need to like recover the i and j indices, you do modulo stuff using the size of the extents of the dimensions to figure out the coordinates of your point. Now, this assumes, of course, that all the elements are in some contiguous storage and that you can just iterate through. So this approach is nice because your element-wise iteration using your iterator is nice and fast.
So the first way to write a multidimensional iterator is to collapse the indexing. So you sort of end up losing information here. You don't keep track of both i and j. You just keep like one, like where am I in the sequence number? And if you ever need to like recover the i and j indices, you do modulo stuff using the size of the extents of the dimensions to figure out the coordinates of your point. Now, this assumes, of course, that all the elements are in some contiguous storage and that you can just iterate through. So this approach is nice because your element-wise iteration using your iterator is nice and fast.|||所以，编写多维迭代器的第一种方法是折叠索引。因此，你在这里会丢失一些信息。你不会同时跟踪 i 和 j。你只保留一个数字，比如我位于序列号的什么位置？如果你需要恢复 i 和 j 索引，你可以使用维度范围的大小来进行取模运算，以此算出点的坐标。当然，这假设所有元素都存储在连续的内存中，并且你可以直接遍历。所以这种方法很好，因为使用迭代器进行逐元素的遍历非常快。
You just do an increment every time. It's just like a pointer, basically, or a stood vector iterator. But any time that you need to recover the indices, you have to do some expensive modulo math. And that can be slow. That can become divisions, which are notoriously a slow operation. So we don't generally like that approach. Although if we wanted to just have iterators solely for the purpose of doing element-wise operations like reductions or fines
You just do an increment every time. It's just like a pointer, basically, or a stood vector iterator. But any time that you need to recover the indices, you have to do some expensive modulo math. And that can be slow. That can become divisions, which are notoriously a slow operation. So we don't generally like that approach. Although if we wanted to just have iterators solely for the purpose of doing element-wise operations like reductions or finds|||你每次只需执行自增操作即可。它基本上就像一个指针，或者像一个 std::vector 迭代器。但每当你需要恢复索引时，你都必须进行开销很大的取模运算。这可能会很慢。这会变成除法运算，而除法运算是出了名的慢操作。所以我们通常不喜欢这种方法。尽管如果我们只是为了进行诸如归约或查找之类的逐元素操作而需要迭代器的话，这可能是一个相当不错的方法。
or stuff like that, that would probably be a pretty good approach. The other approach is to do a multidimensional iterator that actually keeps track of the indices. So instead of it just iterating through the underlying data, it maintains the indices and updates them. Now, the problem with this is, and I'll actually show you, because back in the day when I worked actually show you, because back in the day, when I worked at Berkeley Lab, I spent a substantial amount of time doing research on this general problem space. So the problem is, when you're doing this,
or stuff like that, that would probably be a pretty good approach. The other approach is to do a multidimensional iterator that actually keeps track of the indices. So instead of it just iterating through the underlying data, it maintains the indices and updates them. Now, the problem with this is, and I'll actually show you, because back in the day when I worked actually show you, because back in the day, when I worked at Berkeley Lab, I spent a substantial amount of time doing research on this general problem space. So the problem is, when you're doing this,|||诸如此类的事情，这可能是一个相当不错的方法。另一种方法是编写一个真正跟踪索引的多维迭代器。因此，它不仅仅是遍历底层数据，而是维护并更新索引。现在，这种方法的问题在于——我实际上会向你们展示，因为当年我在工作时……实际上向你们展示，因为当年在劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室工作时，我花了相当长的时间研究这个普遍的问题领域。所以问题在于，当你这样做时，
you are basically embedding one for loop inside of your multiple for loops potentially inside of your iterator. So I'm going to show you an example of what I mean here. I'm going to share my screen. I'm not going to show you the listener. I'm going to show Connor the co-host. I was thinking thinking i'm sure the listener understands that when you say you you mean me not the listener because this is a podcast and yeah they're not seeing anything although we'll this looks like a open source on your page so we'll we'll include a link to index underscore iterator dot hpp in uh bryce's one of bryce repos here? Let's imagine we've got some for loop that's, you know, iterating over some two-dimensional iterator, you know, like a range-based for loop
you are basically embedding one for loop inside of your multiple for loops potentially inside of your iterator. So I'm going to show you an example of what I mean here. I'm going to share my screen. I'm not going to show you the listener. I'm going to show Connor the co-host. I was thinking thinking i'm sure the listener understands that when you say you you mean me not the listener because this is a podcast and yeah they're not seeing anything although we'll this looks like a open source on your page so we'll we'll include a link to index underscore iterator dot hpp in uh bryce's one of bryce repos here? Let's imagine we've got some for loop that's, you know, iterating over some two-dimensional iterator, you know, like a range-based for loop|||你基本上是在你的多个循环中（可能是在你的迭代器内部）嵌入了一个 for 循环。所以我将向你展示一个例子，说明我在这里的意思。我要共享我的屏幕。我不是在给听众看。我是给联合主持人 Connor 看。我一直在想，我确信听众能理解，当你对我说“你”时，你指的是我，而不是听众，因为这是一档播客，是的，他们什么也看不到，虽然我们会……这看起来像是你页面上的一个开源项目，所以我们会在 Bryce 的某个代码库中附上指向 index_iterator.hpp 的链接。让我们想象一下，我们有一些 for 循环，你知道的，正在遍历某个二维迭代器，你知道的，比如基于范围的 for 循环
over some two-dimensional iterator. So one of the things it's going to do, it's going to call increment on those iterators. So it's going to do operator++ on those iterators. And then it's going to do some amount of comparisons to check whether it's reached the end iterator. But let's just focus on the increment right now. So what happens when you increment one of these multidimensional iterators. Well, you can't just increment both of the indices or one of the indices. You also have to check whether you've reached the end of one of the rows. And so, like, what you do is, you know, the code that I have before Connor, I do increment the i or the first index, and then check whether we've reached the end of that extent.
over some two-dimensional iterator. So one of the things it's going to do, it's going to call increment on those iterators. So it's going to do operator++ on those iterators. And then it's going to do some amount of comparisons to check whether it's reached the end iterator. But let's just focus on the increment right now. So what happens when you increment one of these multidimensional iterators. Well, you can't just increment both of the indices or one of the indices. You also have to check whether you've reached the end of the row. And so, like, what you do is, you know, the code that I have before Connor, I do increment the i or the first index, and then check whether we've reached the end of that extent.|||遍历某个二维迭代器。所以它要做的一件事是，调用这些迭代器的 increment。因此它会对这些迭代器执行 operator++。然后它会进行一定数量的比较，以检查是否已经到达末尾迭代器。但现在我们只关注自增（increment）。那么，当你对其中一个多维迭代器执行自增时会发生什么呢？嗯，你不能只同时增加两个索引或只增加其中一个索引。你还必须检查是否已经到达行尾。所以，就像你做的那样，你看，在 Connor 面前的代码中，我确实增加了 i 或第一个索引，然后检查我们是否到达了该范围的末尾。
And if we have, then increment the j index and reset the i index to zero. Now, that means that there's an if statement in there. So conditional or control flow, a branch. And I've put these little comments next to some of these operations here. Like next to that first increment of the i-index, I've written inner loop iteration expression. And then next to the check of whether the first index has reached the end of the row,
And if we have, then increment the j index and reset the i index to zero. Now, that means that there's an if statement in there. So conditional or control flow, a branch. And I've put these little comments next to some of these operations here. Like next to that first increment of the i-index, I've written inner loop iteration expression. And then next to the check of whether the first index has reached the end of the row,|||如果达到了，那么就增加 j 索引并将 i 索引重置为零。这意味着其中包含一个 if 语句。因此存在条件语句或控制流、一个分支。我在其中一些操作旁边加了这些小注释。比如在对 i 索引的第一次自增旁边，我写了“内层循环迭代表达式”（inner loop iteration expression）。然后在检查第一个索引是否到达行尾的检查旁边，
I've written a comment that says inner loop condition. And then I've got the increment of that J index, and I've called that the outer loop increment. And then the reset of the I index to be zero, I've called that the inner loop init statement. And I've added these comments here to make it clear to somebody who's reading this code that inside of this increment operator is the logic or most of the logic of what would
I've written a comment that says inner loop condition. And then I've got the increment of that J index, and I've called that the outer loop increment. And then the reset of the I index to be zero, I've called that the inner loop init statement. And I've added these comments here to make it clear to somebody who's reading this code that inside of this increment operator is the logic or most of the logic of what would|||我写了一条注释，说“内层循环条件”（inner loop condition）。然后我进行了 J 索引的自增，我称之为“外层循环自增”（outer loop increment）。然后将 I 索引重置为零的操作，我称之为“内层循环初始化语句”（inner loop init statement）。我在这里添加这些注释是为了向阅读此代码的人明确说明，在这个自增运算符内部包含着……的逻辑，或者说大部分逻辑：如果
be a language for loop if you were instead writing this as like a C style nested for loops. So if instead of using this fancy 2D index iterator, you were just to write one for loop over the i indices or one for loop over the j indices and then one inner for loop over the i indices, that inner i-indice- C for loop in this code, it becomes part of that logic gets put into this increment operator. And then some of the other logic. So I mentioned the outer loop increment is inside of this increment operator.
be a language for loop if you were instead writing this as like a C style nested for loops. So if instead of using this fancy 2D index iterator, you were just to write one for loop over the i indices or one for loop over the j indices and then one inner for loop over the i indices, that inner i-indice- C for loop in this code, it becomes part of that logic gets put into this increment operator. And then some of the other logic. So I mentioned the outer loop increment is inside of this increment operator.|||如果你把它写成 C 风格的嵌套 for 循环，那它就会是一个语言级别的 for 循环。所以，如果你不使用这个花哨的二维索引迭代器，而是只写一个针对 i 索引的 for 循环，或者一个针对 j 索引的 for 循环，然后再写一个针对 i 索引的内层 for loop，那么在这段代码中，那个内层的 i 索引 C for 循环的一部分逻辑就被放进了这个自增运算符中。还有其他一些逻辑。所以我提到外层循环自增是在这个自增运算符内部。
Now, the outer loop init statement is going to happen in the actual for loop where you use this index iterator. And ditto for the condition where you check whether the index iterator has reached the end. But the point here is that we've embedded a for loop into this iterator. And the problem is that the compiler doesn't understand that for loop, that inner loop. Compilers are pretty good at understanding loops and optimizing based on loops, and especially multidimensional loops. But all of that relies upon a compiler being able to lower loops to some canonical form that it understands, and be like, hey, this is, like this is a loop and like, like then here's an inner loop within it. At the IR level and compilers, like at the LLVM IR level, there is no loop construct. There's just, you know, a series of lower level, you know, assembly-ish operations. But the LLVM backend understands how to recognize a loop in that form.
Now, the outer loop init statement is going to happen in the actual for loop where you use this index iterator. And ditto for the condition where you check whether the index iterator has reached the end. But the point here is that we've embedded a for loop into this iterator. And the problem is that the compiler doesn't understand that for loop, that inner loop. Compilers are pretty good at understanding loops and optimizing based on loops, and especially multidimensional loops. But all of that relies upon a compiler being able to lower loops to some canonical form that it understands, and be like, hey, this is, like this is a loop and like, like then here's an inner loop within it. At the IR level and compilers, like at the LLVM IR level, there is no loop construct. There's just, you know, a series of lower level, you know, assembly-ish operations. But the LLVM backend understands how to recognize a loop in that form.|||现在，外层循环初始化语句将发生在使用这个索引迭代器的实际 for 循环中。检查索引迭代器是否到达末尾的条件也是如此。但这里的重点是，我们将一个 for 循环嵌入到了这个迭代器中。问题在于，编译器并不理解那个 for 循环、那个内层循环。编译器非常擅长理解循环并基于循环进行优化，尤其是多维循环。但这一切都依赖于编译器能够将循环降低（lower）为其理解的某种规范形式，并认为：嘿，这是一个循环，然后这里面还有一个内层循环。在 IR 级别和编译器中，比如在 LLVM IR 级别，没有循环结构。只有一系列更低级别的、类似于汇编的操作。但 LLVM 后端知道如何识别这种形式的循环。
One of the problems with these multidimensional iterators is that the compiler doesn't understand that this control flow logic that's inside of this increment operator is actually an inner loop. And so it can't do things like avoid having to do that if check every iteration. And it can't do things like vectorize or unroll the loop or any of the loop optimizations that actually make loops fast.
One of the problems with these multidimensional iterators is that the compiler doesn't understand that this control flow logic that's inside of this increment operator is actually an inner loop. And so it can't do things like avoid having to do that if check every iteration. And it can't do things like vectorize or unroll the loop or any of the loop optimizations that actually make loops fast.|||这些多维迭代器的问题之一在于，编译器不理解这个自增运算符内部的控制流逻辑实际上是一个内层循环。因此它无法做到诸如避免在每次迭代中都执行 if 检查之类的事情。它也无法做到诸如向量化、循环展开或任何真正能让循环变快的循环优化。
So one of the cool things that I experimented with back in the day was, well, maybe we could trick the compiler by using coroutines, specifically using generators. So what if we had a, uh, uh, uh, coroutine that would, like the body of the coroutine would just be two for loops, an outer for loop over the J indices and an inner for loop over the I indices. And inside of that innermost loop, you would just co-yield the current indices. And then this coroutine would return you some generator type. And then every element of this generator type
So one of the cool things that I experimented with back in the day was, well, maybe we could trick the compiler by using coroutines, specifically using generators. So what if we had a, uh, uh, uh, coroutine that would, like the body of the coroutine would just be two for loops, an outer for loop over the J indices and an inner for loop over the I indices. And inside of that innermost loop, you would just co-yield the current indices. And then this coroutine would return you some generator type. And then every element of this generator type|||所以，我当年尝试过的一件很酷的事情是，嗯，也许我们可以通过使用协程（coroutine）来欺骗编译器，具体来说是使用生成器（generator）。如果我们有一个……嗯……协程，它的主体就是两个 for 循环：一个针对 J 索引的外层 for 循环和一个针对 I 索引的内层 for 循环。在该最内层循环内部，你只需 co-yield 当前的索引。然后这个协程会返回给你某种生成器类型。接着，这个生成器类型的每个元素
would be one of these indices. And the idea behind this was, well, if you do it this way, in the cases where the compiler does all the coroutine optimizations and inlines essentially the code in the coroutine body in place, so it does the heap elision and the de-virtualization optimizations, then essentially what it's going to do is it's going to take these two for loops and just sort of inline them into the place where you use them.
would be one of these indices. And the idea behind this was, well, if you do it this way, in the cases where the compiler does all the coroutine optimizations and inlines essentially the code in the coroutine body in place, so it does the heap elision and the de-virtualization optimizations, then essentially what it's going to do is it's going to take these two for loops and just sort of inline them into the place where you use them.|||都将是这些索引之一。背后的想法是，如果你用这种方法，在编译器执行所有协程优化并基本上将协程体中的代码就地内联（inline）的情况下（即它执行了堆省略和去虚化优化），那么本质上它要做的是，将这两个 for 循环内联到你使用它们的地方。
And then because it's done that, the loops should get lowered in a way where the compiler backend understands them. So you can write code that's just, you know, C++, you know, stood for each over some iterators, but it will be as if you'd written the efficient code of the nested C-style for loops. And that technique actually kind of worked, but, you know, that's not really a production solution because you don't want your multidimensional iterators, the performance of your multidimensional iterators to be entirely dependent upon coroutine optimizations kicking in. that we could come up with some set of compiler extensions that you could use inside of an iterator to say like, hey, I'm signaling to you
And then because it's done that, the loops should get lowered in a way where the compiler backend understands them. So you can write code that's just, you know, C++, you know, stood for each over some iterators, but it will be as if you'd written the efficient code of the nested C-style for loops. And that technique actually kind of worked, but, you know, that's not really a production solution because you don't want your multidimensional iterators, the performance of your multidimensional iterators to be entirely dependent upon coroutine optimizations kicking in. that we could come up with some set of compiler extensions that you could use inside of an iterator to say like, hey, I'm signaling to you|||而且由于它这样做了，循环应该会以编译器后端能够理解的方式被降低。因此，你可以编写这样的代码：你知道的，C++，你知道的，用 std::for_each 遍历一些迭代器，但它的效果就好像你写了高效的嵌套 C 风格 for 循环代码一样。这项技术实际上在某种程度上起作用了，但是，你知道的，这并不是真正的生产环境解决方案，因为你不会希望你的多维迭代器、多维迭代器的性能完全依赖于协程优化的触发。我们可以想出一套编译器扩展，你可以在迭代器内部使用它来表达，比如：“嘿，我在向你发出信号
that this is a multidimensional iterator and that I've got this logic of a for loop embedded inside of this iterator. And you, compiler, should be aware of that so that you can recognize that for loop and optimize accordingly. But until we have that, it is unlikely that we will add multidimensional iterators
that this is a multidimensional iterator and that I've got this logic of a for loop embedded inside of this iterator. And you, compiler, should be aware of that so that you can recognize that for loop and optimize accordingly. But until we have that, it is unlikely that we will add multidimensional iterators|||这是一个多维迭代器，我的这个迭代器内部嵌入了一个 for 循环的逻辑。你，编译器，应该意识到这一点，以便你能识别那个 for 循环并进行相应的优化。”但在我们拥有这种功能之前，我们不太可能会把多维迭代器
to things like mdspan because we would rather not have that instead of having a slow version of that. So here is a question. In a world where the generic algorithms provided by the standard library of C++ are able to work on these MD spans, and I've heard that they've MD arrays. There's also a proposal for that. So in some future C++ standard, there will both be an MD array and an MD spam potentially. And in a world where you have one of these future multidimensional iterators that enables you to use the generic algorithms on these MD arrays and MD spans for shape preserving algorithms, such as like transforms i think there's no question sort of how those work right because it's a atomic operation that you're applying to each atom or element in your multi-dimensional array but how does like a reduction work because in the array language world, you have a way of specifying the rank or the axis on which the reduction occurs.
to things like mdspan because we would rather not have that instead of having a slow version of that. So here is a question. In a world where the generic algorithms provided by the standard library of C++ are able to work on these MD spans, and I've heard that they've MD arrays. There's also a proposal for that. So in some future C++ standard, there will both be an MD array and an MD spam potentially. And in a world where you have one of these future multidimensional iterators that enables you to use the generic algorithms on these MD arrays and MD spans for shape preserving algorithms, such as like transforms i think there's no question sort of how those work right because it's a atomic operation that you're applying to each atom or element in your multi-dimensional array but how does like a reduction work because in the array language world, you have a way of specifying the rank or the axis on which the reduction occurs.|||添加到诸如 mdspan 之类的东西中，因为我们宁愿没有它，也不愿有一个性能低下的版本。所以这里有一个问题。在这样一个世界里：C++ 标准库提供的通用算法能够作用于这些 MD span（我还听说它们有 MD array，这也有一个提案。因此在未来的某些 C++ 标准中，可能会同时存在 MD array 和 MD span）。在这样一个世界里，如果你拥有这些未来的多维迭代器之一，它使你能够将通用算法用于这些 MD array 和 MD span 上，用于形状保持算法（shape preserving algorithms），例如转换（transforms）——我认为毫无疑问这些是如何工作的，对吧？因为你对多维数组中的每个原子或元素应用的是一个原子操作。但是归约（reduction）是如何工作的呢？因为在数组语言的世界里，你有一种方法可以指定归约发生的秩（rank）或轴（axis）。
Because when you do a reduction on a matrix, you can sum row-wise, you can sum column-wise, and as soon as you start to deal with cubes or hypercubes? Is there a way of using generic algorithms? That's a great question. And it gets to the other more subtle part of multidimensional iterators. So when you're iterating through a one-dimensional set of elements, how many ways are there to iterate through? I mean, it depends on the exact version of that question you're asking, but it's either one or two. Forwards or forwards and backwards.
Because when you do a reduction on a matrix, you can sum row-wise, you can sum column-wise, and as soon as you start to deal with cubes or hypercubes? Is there a way of using generic algorithms? That's a great question. And it gets to the other more subtle part of multidimensional iterators. So when you're iterating through a one-dimensional set of elements, how many ways are there to iterate through? I mean, it depends on the exact version of that question you're asking, but it's either one or two. Forwards or forwards and backwards.|||因为当你对矩阵进行归约时，你可以按行求和，可以按列求和，而一旦你开始处理立方体或超立方体呢？有没有办法使用通用算法？这是一个极好的问题。这就触及了多维迭代器的另一个更微妙的部分。所以，当你遍历一组一维元素时，有多少种遍历方式？我的意思是，这取决于你问的是该问题的哪个具体版本，但要么是一种，要么是两种。正向，或者正向和反向。
Wrong. Wrong. What you answered was the two reasonable ways of doing that. But you could imagine other ways. Like you could start in the middle and spiral out. Yeah, some pancake or shuffle thing. You could do weird things like that. But like that's not, you know, that's not going to be super common.
Wrong. Wrong. What you answered was the two reasonable ways of doing that. But you could imagine other ways. Like you could start in the middle and spiral out. Yeah, some pancake or shuffle thing. You could do weird things like that. But like that's not, you know, that's not going to be super common.|||错。错。你回答的是两种合理的方法。但你可以想象其他方法。比如你可以从中间开始向外螺旋。是的，某种煎饼式（pancake）或洗牌式的东西。你可以做诸诸如此类奇怪的事情。但那并不是，你知道的，那不会非常常见。
But your answer of two, like there's two reasonable ways, forward and backwards. Yeah, that's pretty spot on. And I'm going to posit that in like a lot of cases, maybe 80% or 85%, maybe even 90% of times. You know, you just really care about going forward, right? Now, in multidimensional space, there's a lot more iteration orders. There's a lot more options. And more importantly, there's a lot more reasonable options options and perhaps even more importantly unlike in the one-dimensional case there's not a clear default and the one-dimensional case go going from like start to end like going forward like that is i think everybody will agree that is a pretty reasonable like default like if you don't ask for something special that's what should happen That is, I think everybody will agree, that is a pretty reasonable default.
But your answer of two, like there's two reasonable ways, forward and backwards. Yeah, that's pretty spot on. And I'm going to posit that in like a lot of cases, maybe 80% or 85%, maybe even 90% of times. You know, you just really care about going forward, right? Now, in multidimensional space, there's a lot more iteration orders. There's a lot more options. And more importantly, there's a lot more reasonable options options and perhaps even more importantly unlike in the one-dimensional case there's not a clear default and the one-dimensional case go going from like start to end like going forward like that is i think everybody will agree that is a pretty reasonable like default like if you don't ask for something special that's what should happen That is, I think everybody will agree, that is a pretty reasonable default.|||但你关于“两种”的回答，即有两种合理的方法（正向和反向），是的，非常准确。我要断言，在很多情况下——也许 80% 或 85%，甚至 90% 的情况下——你知道的，你其实只关心向前遍历，对吧？现在，在多维空间中，有更多的遍历顺序。有更多的选项。更重要的是，有更多合理的选项，而且可能更重要的是，与一维情况不同，这里没有一个明确的默认值。在一维情况下，从起点到终点进行正向遍历，我想每个人都会同意这是一个非常合理的默认值——如果你没有提出特殊要求，那就应该这样。也就是，我想每个人都会同意，这是一个非常合理的默认值。
If you don't ask for something special, that's what should happen. But it's a lot more complicated for even something like a matrix, a two-dimensional thing. Do you go row-wise first or do you go column-wise first? There's not one of those two that's a right default but i mean array language people would disagree but continue um i'm i'm uh no there's something there's something that's coming out the day after this gets released the next episode of array cast there's a whole discussion on rank and something called leading axis theory which is basically a theory that came out of array languages
If you don't ask for something special, that's what should happen. But it's a lot more complicated for even something like a matrix, a two-dimensional thing. Do you go row-wise first or do you go column-wise first? There's not one of those two that's a right default but i mean array language people would disagree but continue um i'm i'm uh no there's something there's something that's coming out the day after this gets released the next episode of array cast there's a whole discussion on rank and something called leading axis theory which is basically a theory that came out of array languages|||如果你没有要求特殊的东西，就应该这样做。但对于像矩阵甚至二维事物这样的东西，事情要复杂得多。你是先按行遍历还是先按列遍历？这两个选项中并没有哪一个理所当然是正确的默认设置，不过我的意思是数组语言圈的人会对此持不同意见，但请继续……我……不，有些事情……有些事情在这个节目发布后的第二天就会推出，下一期的 ArrayCast 有一整集关于“秩”（rank）以及被称为“主导轴理论”（leading axis theory）的讨论，这基本上是源自数组语言的一种理论
that asserts that uh you should always your generic algorithm or your algorithm should operate or be implemented such that the default is uh the leading axis. And that way you can use something like a rank operator to drill down to any level of granularity that you want. And if you do it any other way, you've basically limited the scope of functionality that you can implement. And that is a great answer for theorists. But in the real world... What do you mean? APL is in the real world what do you mean apl is in the real world in the real world where um uh performance matters and where the uh memory access patterns um uh often are the deciding factor and whether your code is fast or slow.
that asserts that uh you should always your generic algorithm or your algorithm should operate or be implemented such that the default is uh the leading axis. And that way you can use something like a rank operator to drill down to any level of granularity that you want. And if you do it any other way, you've basically limited the scope of functionality that you can implement. And that is a great answer for theorists. But in the real world... What do you mean? APL is in the real world what do you mean apl is in the real world in the real world where um uh performance matters and where the uh memory access patterns um uh often are the deciding factor and whether your code is fast or slow.|||它断言，呃，你的通用算法或你的算法应该这样运行或实现：默认情况下采用主导轴。这样你就可以使用类似秩运算符（rank operator）之类的东西深入到你想要的任何粒度级别。如果你用任何其他方式，你基本上就限制了你可以实现的功​​能范围。对于理论家来说，这是一个完美的答案。但在现实世界中……你这话什么意思？APL 就在现实世界中，你什么意思 APL 在现实世界中？在现实世界中，呃，性能至关重要，而且内存访问模式通常是你的代码是快还是慢的决定性因素。
What you've just said is not necessarily true. I mean, I'm not the right person to answer this question because I have not fully implemented an array language interpreter or compiler that includes a rank operator. But Marshall Lockbaum, who has implemented multiple array languages and was one of the subject matter experts on that episode, said that leading access theory necessitates that you get the best performance in terms of like contiguous elements being operated in.
What you've just said is not necessarily true. I mean, I'm not the right person to answer this question because I have not fully implemented an array language interpreter or compiler that includes a rank operator. But Marshall Lockbaum, who has implemented multiple array languages and was one of the subject matter experts on that episode, said that leading access theory necessitates that you get the best performance in terms of like contiguous elements being operated in.|||你刚才所说的并不一定正确。我的意思是，我不是回答这个问题的合适人选，因为我没有完整实现过包含秩运算符的数组语言解释器或编译器。但是 Marshall Lockbaum——他实现过多种数组语言，也是那一期的专题专家之一——表示，主导轴理论（leading axis theory）确保了你在对连续元素进行操作时能够获得最佳性能。
Right, but what if you're on a platform where you don't necessarily want every thread to be accessing contiguous elements? For example, a GPU. On a GPU, you want all of the threads in a warp to be accessing different elements. Or you want them to be processing different streams. You don't want in a single iteration, you don't want all 32 threads of the warp to be accessing 32 contiguous elements that are right
Right, but what if you're on a platform where you don't necessarily want every thread to be accessing contiguous elements? For example, a GPU. On a GPU, you want all of the threads in a warp to be accessing different elements. Or you want them to be processing different streams. You don't want in a single iteration, you don't want all 32 threads of the warp to be accessing 32 contiguous elements that are right|||对，但如果你处于这样一个平台上：你并不一定希望每个线程都去访问连续的元素呢？例如，GPU。在 GPU 上，你希望 warp（线程束）中的所有线程都去访问不同的元素。或者你希望它们处理不同的流。在单次迭代中，你不希望 warp 的所有 32 个线程都去访问正紧挨着的
next to each other because what you instead want is you want thread zero to be accessing you know some element and then thread one to be accessing some element that's at a stride away from that element because you want thread zero to be able to prefetch all of the subsequent elements that it's going to be touching. Like the, whether or not you want contiguous access or strided access, like these memory patterns, it tends to change whether you're on a, know a simp t type architecture or a sim d type architecture now sure within a within a single thread it may be the case that um uh that you always want contiguous access but but like just as like a counterpoint to the example i just gave if i'm on a cpu um uh a CPU and I have a bunch of threads on the same core, I might want them all to be accessing elements that have a great deal of locality because I want it to stay within cache. But if I'm on a GPU, I might care more about being able to overlap and hide my memory latency. So wait, let me ask a potentially a question that will show my ignorance about how GPUs work.
next to each other because what you instead want is you want thread zero to be accessing you know some element and then thread one to be accessing some element that's at a stride away from that element because you want thread zero to be able to prefetch all of the subsequent elements that it's going to be touching. Like the, whether or not you want contiguous access or strided access, like these memory patterns, it tends to change whether you're on a, know a simp t type architecture or a sim d type architecture now sure within a within a single thread it may be the case that um uh that you always want contiguous access but but like just as like a counterpoint to the example i just gad if i'm on a cpu um uh a CPU and I have a bunch of threads on the same core, I might want them all to be accessing elements that have a great deal of locality because I want it to stay within cache. But if I'm on a GPU, I might care more about being able to overlap and hide my memory latency. So wait, let me ask a potentially a question that will show my ignorance about how GPUs work.|||32 个连续元素，因为你真正想要的是：你希望线程 0 访问某个元素，然后让线程 1 访问距离该元素有一定步长（stride）的另一个元素，因为你希望线程 0 能够预取它即将触及的所有后续元素。诸如你是想要连续访问还是步长访问，像这样的内存访问模式，往往会根据你使用的是 SIMT（单指令多线程）架构还是 SIMD（单指令多数据）架构而有所改变。当然，在单个线程内部，情况可能确实是……呃……你总是希望进行连续访问，但作为我刚才举的例子的反例——如果我在 CPU 上，嗯……一个 CPU，并且我在同一个核心上有许多线程，我可能希望它们都去访问具有很高局部性的元素，因为我希望它留在缓存（cache）中。但如果我在 GPU 上，我可能更关心能够重叠并隐藏我的内存延迟。所以等一下，让我问一个可能会暴露我对 GPU 工作原理无知的潜在问题。
Are you saying that for GPUs, if so, you say you've got, let's try and make a concrete example that'll be easier for you to answer. If you have a matrix whatever you can say 10 by 10 elements or 10 million by 10 million elements and it's stored in row major order which is i think i think the naive intuitive way um to think about it but if it's not for you it's the counterintuitive way but so that means if you've got the numbers from you know one to a hundred uh they're stored just as an iota sequence from one to a hundred as if in a vector. And then, you know, your shape is 10 by 10. And so say you want to sum these row wise and you want to sum them column wise.
Are you saying that for GPUs, if so, you say you've got, let's try and make a concrete example that'll be easier for you to answer. If you have a matrix whatever you can say 10 by 10 elements or 10 million by 10 million elements and it's stored in row major order which is i think i think the naive intuitive way um to think about it but if it's not for you it's the counterintuitive way but so that means if you've got the numbers from you know one to a hundred uh they're stored just as an iota sequence from one to a hundred as if in a vector. And then, you know, your shape is 10 by 10. And so say you want to sum these row wise and you want to sum them column wise.|||你是说对于 GPU 来说，如果是这样，你说你拥有——让我们试着举一个具体的例子，这样对你来说更容易回答。如果你有一个矩阵，随便吧，可以说 10x10 个元素或者 1000 万乘以 1000 万个元素，并且它是以行主序（row major order）存储的——这在我看来是最朴素、最直观的思考方式，嗯，但如果你觉得不是，那这就是反直觉的方式。但这意味着如果你有从 1 到 100 的数字，它们就像在一个 vector 中一样，仅仅作为从 1 到 100 的 iota 序列存储。然后，你知道的，你的形状是 10x10。比方说你想按行对这些元素求和，或者你想按列对它们求和。
So in the row wise way, because each set of 10 elements that you want to sum are stored contiguous and contiguously in memory uh you're saying that like in the case where you want to do it column wise and you're skipping every 10 elements so it's slightly it's the exact opposite instead of having each 10 elements you want to sum up together there are 10 elements away from each other you're seeing you're saying that like a gpu might be more performant on the column wise data because threads can do some sort of pre-fetching for the data that they want versus having them stored contiguously like i would assume that whether you're on a cpu or a gpu both like the row wise the rowjor reductions would be more performant.
So in the row wise way, because each set of 10 elements that you want to sum are stored contiguous and contiguously in memory uh you're saying that like in the case where you want to do it column wise and you're skipping every 10 elements so it's slightly it's the exact opposite instead of having each 10 elements you want to sum up together there are 10 elements away from each other you're seeing you're saying that like a gpu might be more performant on the column wise data because threads can do some sort of pre-fetching for the data that they want versus having them stored contiguously like i would assume that whether you're on a cpu or a gpu both like the row wise the rowjor reductions would be more performant.|||因此，在按行求和的方式中，因为你要求和的每组 10 个元素在内存中是连续存储的，呃，你是说，在你想按列求和的情况下，你要跳过每 10 个元素，所以情况正好相反——你要一起求和的每 10 个元素并不是紧挨着的，而是彼此相距 10 个元素。你的意思是，GPU 在按列的数据上可能性能更高，因为线程可以为它们想要的数据做某种预取，而不是像连续存储那样——我会假设，无论你是在 CPU 还是 GPU 上，行方向的归约（row-wise reductions）都会表现得更高性能。
Remember that the... So on the... Think about how the GPU core works. So all 32 threads within a warp are... Hopefully Olivier isn't listening. They're real threads, but like, they're sort of virtualized. Under the hood, it's like one execution unit. So what's going to happen? Okay, we go and load data, right? We're going to go and load, you know, 32 elements of data. All of those threads are going to do it at the same time.
Remember that the... So on the... Think about how the GPU core works. So all 32 threads within a warp are... Hopefully Olivier isn't listening. They're real threads, but like, they're sort of virtualized. Under the hood, it's like one execution unit. So what's going to happen? Okay, we go and load data, right? We're going to go and load, you know, 32 elements of data. All of those threads are going to do it at the same time.|||记住……所以在……想想 GPU 核心是如何工作的。因此，warp 中的所有 32 个线程都是……希望 Olivier 没有在听。它们是真实的线程，但又有点被虚拟化了。在底层，它就像一个执行单元。那么会发生什么呢？好的，我们去加载数据，对吧？我们要去加载，你知道的，32 个元素的数据。所有这些线程将同时执行此操作。
And the reason they're going to do it at the same time is because there's actually only one hardware unit that does the load. Okay. And so we want to load 32 elements of contiguous data, right? That makes sense. So that means that each one of those threads is going to operate on one of those 32 elements, right? And then what are we going to do next? Well, we're talking about a reduction. So then we're going to go load the next element that we're going to add in. And so we'll load another 32 elements. So because those loads have to happen at the same time and we want them all to load, you know, contiguous data, well in fact that they have to. Which elements should thread zero be adding up?
And the reason they're going to do it at the same time is because there's actually only one hardware unit that does the load. Okay. And so we want to load 32 elements of contiguous data, right? That makes sense. So that means that each one of those threads is going to operate on one of those 32 elements, right? And then what are we going to do next? Well, we're talking about a reduction. So then we're going to go load the next element that we're going to add in. And so we'll load another 32 elements. So because those loads have to happen at the same time and we want them all to load, you know, contiguous data, well in fact that they have to. Which elements should thread zero be adding up?|||它们之所以同时进行，是因为实际上只有一个硬件单元负责加载。好的。因此我们想要加载 32 个连续的数据元素，对吧？这讲得通。这意味着这些线程中的每一个都将操作这 32 个元素中的一个，对吧？然后我们接下来要做什么？嗯，我们谈论的是归约。所以接下来我们要去加载我们要加进去的下一个元素。因此我们将加载另外 32 个元素。所以因为这些加载操作必须同时发生，并且我们希望它们都加载，你知道的，连续的数据——事实上它们也必须如此。线程 0 应该把哪些元素相加？
Should thread zero be adding up element zero and one, the elements that are contiguous and next to each other? That doesn't actually make a lot of sense in the GPU programming case, because we want every element, every thread to be working with one element from that first load. Right. So no thread is going to be adding up two contiguous elements. So no, what we want is we want that first thread to be adding up element zero and and the element 31, or index 32, sorry. So the element at the zeroth index and the element at the 32nd index, which will be from the second mode. And then thread one will add up the element at the first and the 33rd index.
Should thread zero be adding up element zero and one, the elements that are contiguous and next to each other? That doesn't actually make a lot of sense in the GPU programming case, because we want every element, every thread to be working with one element from that first load. Right. So no thread is going to be adding up two contiguous elements. So no, what we want is we want that first thread to be adding up element zero and and the element 31, or index 32, sorry. So the element at the zeroth index and the element at the 32nd index, which will be from the second mode. And then thread one will add up the element at the first and the 33rd index.|||线程 0 应该把元素 0 和元素 1 相加吗？即那些连续且彼此相邻的元素？这在 GPU 编程中其实没有什么太大意义，因为我们希望每个元素、每个线程都处理来自第一次加载的那个元素中的一个。对。所以没有哪个线程会将两个连续的元素相加。所以不，我们想要的是，我们希望第一个线程将元素 0 和元素 31（或者说索引 32，抱歉）相加。即第 0 个索引处的元素和第 32 个索引处的元素（后者将来自第二种模式/第二次加载）。然后线程 1 将把第 1 个和第 33 个索引处的元素相加。
So it's not contiguous, but it's a more efficient memory access pattern because we're going to do one load um of like the the 32 elements one of which each thread will use we're going to do two of those back to back interesting so basically you're saying that yeah the the column wise way is is lends itself yeah better on the cpu on the cpu each thread is going to be able to independently do its load and so on the cpu of course we don't want we want um the that zero with thread to be able to load and add together elements zero and one and one of the reasons why wewidth thread to be able to load and add together elements 0 and 1. And one of the reasons why we want it to be contiguous on the CPU is because we want to use vector operations. And vector operations, for the most part, want to operate on contiguous data. whether you want each thread to be accessing your data
So it's not contiguous, but it's a more efficient memory access pattern because we're going to do one load um of like the the 32 elements one of which each thread will use we're going to do two of those back to back interesting so basically you're saying that yeah the the column wise way is is lends itself yeah better on the cpu on the cpu each thread is going to be able to independently do its load and so on the cpu of course we don't want we want um the that zero with thread to be able to load and add together elements zero and one and one of the reasons why wewidth thread to be able to load and add together elements 0 and 1. And one of the reasons why we want it to be contiguous on the CPU is because we want to use vector operations. And vector operations, for the most part, want to operate on contiguous data. whether you want each thread to be accessing your data|||所以它不是连续的，但它是一种更高效的内存访问模式，因为我们将对这 32 个元素（每个线程将使用其中的一个）进行一次加载，我们将连续进行两次这样的加载。有趣，所以基本上你是说，是的，按列的方式更适合在 CPU 上运行。在 CPU 上，每个线程都能够独立地进行加载，因此在 CPU 上，我们当然不希望……我们希望第 0 个线程能够加载并相加元素 0 和元素 1。而我们希望它在 CPU 上连续存储的原因之一，是因为我们想要使用向量操作。而向量操作在绝大多数情况下都希望对连续的数据进行操作。你是否希望每个线程都访问你的数据
contiguously for performance really does depend on the underlying hardware architecture. So once again, I will state that your claim may be correct in theory, but in actual hardware, it's not the case. And this is one of the reasons why it's important to have an iteration model where you can iterate the same structure in different iteration orders, because you might want to change that iteration order depending on what hardware you're running on. Now I will assert
contiguously for performance really does depend on the underlying hardware architecture. So once again, I will state that your claim may be correct in theory, but in actual hardware, it's not the case. And this is one of the reasons why it's important to have an iteration model where you can iterate the same structure in different iteration orders, because you might want to change that iteration order depending on what hardware you're running on. Now I will assert|||为了性能而进行连续访问，其实确实取决于底层的硬件架构。所以再次声明，你的说法在理论上可能是对的，但在实际硬件中并非如此。这也是为什么拥有一个迭代模型很重要的原因之一——在该模型中，你可以用不同的迭代顺序来遍历相同的结构，因为你可能希望根据你运行的硬件来更改该迭代顺序。现在我要断言
that the direction of iteration or this the strategy for iteration, is just a property of whatever iterator you're using. If you've got forward iterators and you want to go in reverse, well then you go and get yourself reverse iterators. And that same logic applies in the multidimensional case. Like you might be able to get multiple different kinds of iterators to the same structure. It sounds like I need to come on ArrayCast and explain some things to your co-hosts and buddies. Well, I mean, yes and no.
that the direction of iteration or this the strategy for iteration, is just a property of whatever iterator you're using. If you've got forward iterators and you want to go in reverse, well then you go and get yourself reverse iterators. And that same logic applies in the multidimensional case. Like you might be able to get multiple different kinds of iterators to the same structure. It sounds like I need to come on ArrayCast and explain some things to your co-hosts and buddies. Well, I mean, yes and no.|||迭代的方向或迭代的策略，仅仅是你所使用的迭代器的属性。如果你有正向迭代器，而你想反向遍历，那么你大可以去找一个反向迭代器来用。同样的逻辑也适用于多维的情况。比如你可能能够针对同一个结构获取多种不同类型的迭代器。听起来我需要上 ArrayCast 节目，向你的联合主持人跟伙伴们解释一些事情了。嗯，我的意思是，既是也不是。
It's just that there is no array language that's ever really been implemented targeting a GPU, specifically like targeting, not going through some, like there is the CodeDefunds, which uses ArrayFire to compile down to run on the GPU. And there's been talks of other array languages trying to do similar things, but there's not been actually like an array language that is directly like implemented in CUDA or some library that uses CUDA or something like that. Meaning that I don't think people have thought about it to this degree. It's like someone with your knowledge about how gpus work
It's just that there is no array language that's ever really been implemented targeting a GPU, specifically like targeting, not going through some, like there is the CodeDefunds, which uses ArrayFire to compile down to run on the GPU. And there's been talks of other array languages trying to do similar things, but there's not been actually like an array language that is directly like implemented in CUDA or some library that uses CUDA or something like that. Meaning that I don't think people have thought about it to this degree. It's like someone with your knowledge about how gpus work|||只是从来没有什么数组语言真正针对 GPU 进行过实现，具体来说是直接针对——而不是通过某些……比如有 CodeDefunds，它使用 ArrayFire 编译并在 GPU 上运行。也有人讨论过其他数组语言试图做类似的事情，但实际上并没有哪种数组语言是直接像用 CUDA 实现的，或者是使用 CUDA 的某些库之类的那样实现的。这意味着我认为人们还没有把问题思考到这个程度。这就像是一个拥有你这样关于 GPU 工作原理知识的人
has not implemented an array language you're gonna you're gonna make you're gonna make me like now i'm gonna have to go redo a part of my of my talk for array what do you mean educate what do you mean you're gonna have to go redo What do you mean? You're going to have to go redo? Let's be honest, Bryce. I was just going to reuse my existing slide deck, but now I'm going to have to go do something. Good. Good. All right. Well, we will continue this topic.
has not implemented an array language you're gonna you're gonna make you're gonna make me like now i'm gonna have to go redo a part of my of my talk for array what do you mean educate what do you mean you're gonna have to go redo What do you mean? You're going to have to go redo? Let's be honest, Bryce. I was just going to reuse my existing slide deck, but now I'm going to have to go do something. Good. Good. All right. Well, we will continue this topic.|||却没有实现过数组语言……你……你快要让我……现在我不得不去重新制作我在 Array 上的演讲的一部分了。你说的教育是什么意思？你说的“你不得不去重新制作”是什么意思？什么意思？你得去重新制作？老实说，Bryce。我本打算直接复用我现有的幻灯片，但现在我不得不去干点活了。很好。很好。好吧，我们继续这个话题。
I have to think. I also am actually now I'm actually confused because I was thinking in my head is that I'm going to have to talk to Marshall about what he meant because really leading Axis, depending on the rank that you specify, like leading access theory is actually going to do the thing where you're strided. that it always leads to the best memory access patterns because your cells are always stored contiguously, a cell being a chunk of the array based on rank. And I mean, it might be what he said, I'm sure, is right. It's not even strictly true for CPUs.
I have to think. I also am actually now I'm actually confused because I was thinking in my head is that I'm going to have to talk to Marshall about what he meant because really leading Axis, depending on the rank that you specify, like leading access theory is actually going to do the thing where you're strided. that it always leads to the best memory access patterns because your cells are always stored contiguously, a cell being a chunk of the array based on rank. And I mean, it might be what he said, I'm sure, is right. It's not even strictly true for CPUs.|||我得想想。我现在其实也有点糊涂了，因为我脑子里在想，我得和 Marshall 谈谈他到底是什么意思，因为实际上，主导轴（leading axis）——根据你指定的秩——比如主导轴理论实际上会做这样的事情：你的访问是带步长的（strided）。它总是能带来最佳的内存访问模式，因为你的单元（cell）总是连续存储的（cell 是指基于秩的数组的一个块）。我的意思是，他说的可能是对的，我相信是对的。这对 CPU 来说甚至都不是严格成立的。
No, no, no. I think I understand what he's saying. I think whatever he was trying to say think I understand what he's saying. I think whatever he was trying to say, I'm sure he is correct. I'm probably misunderstanding what he said. I want... No, no, no. I want to talk to this guy. I want to talk to this guy.
No, no, no. I think I understand what he's saying. I think whatever he was trying to say think I understand what he's saying. I think whatever he was trying to say, I'm sure he is correct. I'm probably misunderstanding what he said. I want... No, no, no. I want to talk to this guy. I want to talk to this guy.|||不，不，不。我想我明白他在说什么。我想无论他试图表达什么，我想我理解他在说什么。我想无论他试图表达什么，我确信他是对的。可能是我误解了他的话。我想……不，不，不。我想和这家伙谈谈。我想和这家伙谈谈。
Marshall can come on ADSP. I'm sure our C++ listeners... Alright, alright. Bring him on. Bring him on. You set that up. Alright. Alright, i'll make it happen i've also got my third podcast he's going to be a guest on that so marshall's just you have a third what you're cheating on me i told you about the third podcast one time in a previous episode but then you interrupted and then it never i put it in the show notes so i've got a few people that
Marshall can come on ADSP. I'm sure our C++ listeners... Alright, alright. Bring him on. Bring him on. You set that up. Alright. Alright, i'll make it happen i've also got my third podcast he's going to be a guest on that so marshall's just you have a third what you're cheating on me i told you about the third podcast one time in a previous episode but then you interrupted and then it never i put it in the show notes so i've got a few people that|||Marshall 可以来参加 ADSP。我相信我们的 C++ 听众……行吧，行吧。把他请来。把他请来。你去安排。好吧。好吧，我会促成这件事的。我还有我的第三档播客，他也会去当嘉宾，所以 Marshall 只是……你有什么第三档？你在背着我搞外遇吗？我在之前的某期节目里跟你提过第三次播客的事，但当时你打断了我，然后就再也没……我把它写进节目简介（show notes）里了，所以我有一些人……
signed up but also i don't have any episodes right now so it's what is your third my third podcast is the programming language podcast we'll we'll end it here stay tuned listen great podcasting some episodes right now. What is your third? My third podcast is the Programming Language Podcast. We'll end it here. Stay tuned, listener. Great podcasting. Some great podcasting. We're bringing Marshall on. We're going to be talking about multidimensional iterators in the future,
注册了，但我现在也没有任何单集，所以，第三个是什么？我的第三个播客是《编程语言播客》，我们就在这里结束吧，听众朋友们请继续关注，精彩的播客，现在有一些单集了。第三个是什么？我的第三个播客是《编程语言播客》。我们就在这里结束吧。听众朋友，请继续关注。精彩的播客。太棒的播客了。我们要请Marshall上节目。我们将讨论未来的多维迭代器，
multidimensional algorithms, and CPU versus GPU. This is going to be exciting. I'm going to have to schedule time to make that keynote talk. Anyways, thanks for tuning in. I'm making notes. We at ADSP, the podcast, plan to stick around for at least as many episodes as CVPcast 294.
多维算法，以及CPU与GPU的对比。这将会令人兴奋。我得安排时间来准备那个主题演讲。总之，谢谢收听。我在记笔记。我们ADSP播客计划继续做下去，至少要做到像CVPcast第294期那样多的期数。
I think that's how many they had. And more apparently, because Bryce committed to you in the last podcast that until one of us drops dead or is murdered by the other person, we're going to continue to do this. That means through kids apparently. I mean, you're going to have to talk to my-
我想他们当时有那么多期。显然还会更多，因为Bryce在上一期播客中向你承诺过，除非我们俩中有一个人倒地身亡或者被对方谋杀，否则我们将继续做下去。这意味着显然要经历养育孩子的阶段。我的意思是，你得去跟我——
I will make an exception if either of us has triplets. Twins, no, we can handle twins. If either of us has triplets, we can take a break. I appreciate that you made whatever percentage of our listeners are parents. They are laughing to themselves extremely hard right now at the idea that you think
如果咱们俩谁生了三胞胎，我会破例。双胞胎不行，双胞胎我们应付得来。如果咱们谁生了三胞胎，我们可以休息一下。我很感激我们的听众中不管百分之几是父母的那些人。他们现在听到你认为
anything below triplets is going to be just like a walk in the park. I am going to have very well-behaved children. Oh, God. That are going to do everything I say. Look, look, look. When I was a child, I had, my mother gave me, there was one room in the house that that was the designated room where I could have my toys.
任何低于三胞胎的情况都会像在公园散步一样轻松，正在心里疯狂大笑呢。我会生出非常听话的孩子。天哪。他们会照着我说的所有话去做。听着，听着，听着。我还是个孩子的时候，我母亲给我，家里有一个房间是被指定的房间，我可以在那里放我的玩具。
And the rest of the house, you'd never think that a child lived there. That's how it's going to be with my kids. They're going to be very neat and orderly i say you are welcome to the listeners that are also parents that are having a good chuckle having a good laugh the entertainment value is brought to you by bruce brice adelstein adelstein well back future parent um and we'll we'll check back in with bryce in uh several years couple years couple years it depends and see how that's going I'll be dead because my children will kill me I'm sure
而家里的其他地方，你绝对想不到那里住过一个孩子。我的孩子也会是这样的。他们会非常整洁有序。我说，欢迎那些同样是父母、正开怀大笑、乐在其中的听众朋友们，娱乐效果由布鲁斯·布莱斯·阿德尔斯坦·阿德尔斯坦倾情奉献。准未来父母，嗯，我们会在几年后、几年后、几年后回访布莱斯，看看到时候情况怎么样。我会死的，因为我的孩子肯定会把我气死
does your mom listen to this podcast? she's probably having a good chuckle right now too she does not listen to this podcast it's too bad nor does the girlfriend thankfully yeah it gives us more freedom like you joking about how easy having anything but
你妈妈听这个播客吗？她现在大概也在开怀大笑吧。她不听这个播客，太遗憾了谢天谢地，女朋友也不听，耶，这给我们更多的自由，就像你开玩笑说养育除了
triplets uh i look forward to my solo podcasts when i'm recording on saturday morning by myself because bryce couldn't make it due to the fact that he was up all night with his young babies um which one of us is going to have kids first? Oh, you definitely. We've already had this conversation. Oh, yeah, we did have this conversation. And then we saved it for episode 200. Ah, yes.
三胞胎之外的其他孩子有多轻松，呃，我很期待我的个人播客，当我周六早上独自录音时，因为布莱斯由于整晚照顾年幼的婴儿而无法出席，嗯，我们俩谁会先生孩子？哦，绝对是你。我们已经讨论过这个了。哦，对，我们确实讨论过这个。然后我们把它留到了第200期。啊，是的。
Yeah, so in three years' time. Actually, less than three years at this point. Two and a half years' time. We're going to have to dig into the vault. Yeah. I've got a very aggressively labeled episode, whatever, 60 something point five. Please do not delete. Because it's gold and we can't delete that.
是的，所以在三年内。其实现在离三年不到。两年半内。我们将不得不挖掘资料库。是的。我有一个贴了非常激进标签的单集，随便什么，第60点几集。请不要删除。因为那是黄金内容，我们不能删掉它。
All right. We've gone over. And thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好了。我们超时了。谢谢收听。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。